[Music]
hello i'm adrian finnegan this is
counting the cost on al jazeera your
weekly look at the world of business and
economics this week
the stakes are rising in the battle over
russian energy putin turns off the gas
taps and the eu proposes a ban on
moscow's oil imports by the end of the
year but what will the energy war cost
also this week russia's ruble hits a
two-year high and its so-called fortress
economy is believed to be holding up so
far but has moscow really weathered the
worst of sanctions
netflix loses subscribers for the first
time in a decade and cnn plus shuts down
its platform just a month after launch
have viewers had enough and is the whole
streaming industry at risk
russia's president vladimir putin is
making good on his threat to turn off
the supply of natural gas to europe
supplies to bulgaria and poland have
been halted after they refuse to pay for
gas in rubles
other european countries may also be cut
off within weeks if they to reject
russia's demand the eu has dismissed the
move as blackmail and is under pressure
to cut the cord on russian energy the
block has proposed a complete ban on all
russian oil imports by the end of the
year
we will make sure that we phase out
russian oil in an orderly fashion
so in a way that allows us and our
partners to secure alternative supply
routes and at the same time be very
careful
that we minimize the impact on the
global market
with all these steps
we are depriving the russian economy
from its ability to diversify and to
modernize
putin wanted to wipe out ukraine from
the map
and he will clearly not succeed
but natural gas has yet to be targeted
with sanctions russia demanded the
european companies pay for gas in euros
to gazprom bank which would then convert
them into rubles in a secondary account
the eu rejected the ultimatum saying
that it violates sanctions but several
european firms had reportedly opened
accounts at gazprom bank to meet
russia's payment demand
poland and bulgaria which refused to pay
in ruble say that they could cope
without russian gas sofia says that it's
made alternative arrangements while
warsaw insists that its energy supplies
are secure however other countries could
be hit hard if russia cut supplies
germany's gas storage facilities are
only 33 and a half percent full italy's
at 35 percent and hungaries are just
19.4 percent but european governments
are fast-tracking regulation that
requires gas stores to be filled to 80
capacity before next winter they've also
set a year-end deadline to cut
two-thirds of gas imports from russia
and plan to eliminate it completely by
2027. a more liquefied natural gas is
being shipped from qatar and the u.s
piped natural gas imports from countries
like norway and algeria will be
increased and the deployment of
renewable energy will be accelerated
among other measures taken to decrease
the dependence on russian energy russia
provides 40 percent of europe's gas and
25 of its oil at a cost of some 850
million dollars a day and that accounts
for at least 40 percent of russia's
revenues
well the price of gas surged by as much
as 20 percent after gazprom suspended
deliveries and the euros value fell
below 1.06 for the first time in five
years
europe's leaders say that they can't
afford the consequences of an immediate
boycott and they're divided over the ban
on russian energy imports
well let's discuss this further with
michael bradshaw professor of global
energy at warwick business school he
joins us now from coventry in the uk
michael european countries can't just
stop using russian gas overnight and yet
here they are faced with this dilemma of
how to keep their supplies going while
not breaching russian sanctions
how are they going to do that
it's very difficult i mean
and i think it's it's a deliberate ploy
by by vladimir putin to make life
difficult to drive division so uh you
know there it's a very technical issue
about how they should make their
payments payments to into gazprom bank
and the european commission's determined
that you know if you if you do what the
russians do then you're in breach of
sanctions actually i don't think the
european politicians want to see the gas
stop flowing
because the gas situation is pretty
pretty difficult president putin has
made good on his threat though to to cut
off the gas he's already done it to
bulgaria and to poland who could be
next well i think you know they
selectively chose those countries i mean
that those countries had said they
wouldn't follow the payment regime
poland had already decided it wasn't
going to renew its contract with russia
at the end of the year and bulgaria is
not a major importer i think it really
determined what will determine this is
what happens with the major importing
countries places such as germany and
italy um who are not only
highly dependent on russian gas but it's
a large volume of gas and their
industry's reliance on that so i mean i
think
sorry go ahead i was going to ask you
what all this is going to do to the
price of gas as well
we as consumers
does it mean that wherever we are in the
world are going to be paying more for
natural gas
yes and no i mean i think this is
affecting the sort of the short-term
spot market if you like a lot of the
natural gas that's traded as lng into
asia is on long-term contracts and is
actually indexed to the oil price it's
primarily in europe where we've got a
reliance on short-term spot markets and
the markets are there's a very large
fear factor in the price of gas
interestingly or also the gas price of
gas although it's much lower in the
united states has been going up because
of demand for gas to export to europe so
yes it will affect every consumer in
europe in the united states um and
eventually in asia as they will also
have to draw on the spot market but in
the northern hemisphere of course we're
moving into summer and gas demand is
always lower then
what is president putin's strategy here
he's not going to shoot himself in the
foot by cutting off gas supplies to
major customers he he must have a plan
here
well talk about shorting shooting
himself in the foot i mean i think this
whole question of of the war in ukraine
i can't see that are there any winners
in it i don't see what putin is standing
to gain from destroying that you know
the position of russia as a reliable
supplier of fossil fuels to europe so if
he has a plan um it's probably already
backfired
can the russian economy withstand the
loss of so much energy revenue
well the thing at the moment of course
is that it's when you talk about revenue
the prices are so high that if the
volumes fall the revenue still remains
quite high and in fact in the last six
months natural gas imports have earned
huge amounts of money and in the past
they used to be very much second second
place to oil again the oil price is also
high but russia is trading its oil at a
very significant discount at the moment
but it is finding buyers i think over
the longer term
this will start to have a major impact
on the russian economy um it will take
time for russia for europe to find
alternative sources of supply and it
will be costly and difficult for you for
russia to find alternative markets for
its oil so i would think you know over
the longer term period this will really
start to impact on the russian economy
you say that russia is finding buyers
where are those buyers china they're in
they're in asia is that are they going
to be able to fill the gap that europe
is leaving
well yes and no i mean i think that yes
there's been talk of chinese buyers i
think that they're not the national oil
companies i think they're the smallest
the smaller private refineries india has
been taking some cargos but not the size
the volumes um that russia has been
exports to europe europe's by far it's
its most important market it's also
having just you know to send that oil
further on ships and it's struggling to
find ships and get insurance for
shipping so all those things are going
to make it much more difficult to to
maintain exports and earnings um at the
level they have been in in the recent
past it it's that it's not an easy
matter something to sort of readjust
markets this way are there enough energy
alternatives for europe to plug the gaps
then if it's not reliant upon or not
relying as much upon
russian gas and oil
again it's some question of time and if
you look at the various plans which have
come out from the international energy
agency and from the european union
itself i mean in the short term it's
going to be very challenging they're
talking about importing more lng which
is already happening from the united
states but they're also looking at the
demand side of the equation what can we
do to reduce the amount of of gas for
example that we consume and of course
these very high prices of oil for
example they'd also drive demand
destruction people drive less they're
much more cautious about their energy
usage so a combination of demand side
factors perhaps and and some
reorientation of supply but there is
still going to be a gap and if if gas
deliveries do get disrupted in that
coming next winter then we'll be we'll
we'll be seeing potentially power cuts
in industry having to shut down we'll
come back to that in in just a moment
because that's an important point but in
the meantime you mentioned about
people looking to alternative supplies
will this crisis hasten do you think
that the shift accelerate the transition
to renewable energy supplies
well very much so that's the intent in
europe with that with their various
plans and it's also intent in the uk
with our energy strategy that this is
going to accelerate the transition away
so it's not just about moving away from
russian oil and gas it's accelerating
the move away from oil and gas from
anywhere by promoting the low carbon
transition so we talked a few moments
ago about president putin perhaps
shooting himself in the foot here with
having a an unrealistic strategy
if we're going to be facing power cuts
in in europe as early as next winter
could it be argued that perhaps european
leaders are doing the same they're going
to hurt themselves economically by
moving away from russian gas and oil
yes absolutely and i think you'll see
that some european leaders in the last
last day also have talked about
sanctions as being a double-edged sword
and you hear a similar sort of rhetoric
from from putin in the terms of europe's
hurting itself but i mean that's the
price that we have to pay if we're going
to to you know do
take actions that really do hurt russia
but yes it is going to have an impact
there's no doubt about that are there
any winners
in in this situation
it's hard to find them um you know i
mean obviously at the moment
international companies are delivering
record profits so i'm assuming that
other royal exporting states doing well
but the knock-on effect of these very
high prices may be very negative in
terms of the global economy and and that
may again drive demand destruction and
and less income so i think
just coming out of the pandemic and
having this level of
disruption in the global economy is not
good for anyone
and i can't see any real winners from
this
professor it's been really good to talk
to you on counting the cost many thanks
indeed for being with us
thank you very much bye
so why does the russian president want
payments in rubles well one answer could
be to shore up the currency which
plunged to historic lows after vladimir
putin sent his troops into ukraine
unleashing unprecedented western
sanctions that have battered the russian
economy but now thanks in part to higher
commodities prices banks have returned
to a liquidity surplus and the ruble has
rallied hitting a two-year high against
the euro and the dollar and the central
bank has reversed its policy of steep
increases to borrowing costs interest
rates have been cut by a further three
percent in an attempt to boost the
economy the main lending rate which was
raised in the immediate aftermath of the
invasion is now at 14
russia has imposed capital controls to
prevent russians moving their money out
of the country and requires the
country's exporters to convert most of
their foreign currency revenues into
rubles
and the ruble has gained more ground
after the country said that it managed
to pay back creditors with dollars as
russia tries to avoid defaulting on its
debts the russian finance ministry said
that it made a 565 billion euro bond
payment that was due this year as well
as settling an 84 million euro bond that
was set to mature in two years russia
has lost access to much of its foreign
currency reserves due to sanctions and
wants to pay lenders in rubles but
credit ratings agencies have rejected
that suggestion
but russia is expected to suffer a deep
recession the central bank warned that
the economy may face two straight years
of contraction estimated at up to 10
this year it also expects inflation to
increase by around 20 percent over the
coming months and the interruptions to
supply chains caused by the sanctions
are crippling russia's production
capacities there was a 72 drop in
passenger car production in the country
for example in march
well joining us now from london is
tatiana orlova lead emerging market
economist at oxford economics tatiana
good to have you with us the first
question has to be why is president
putin insisting right now that energy
payments have to be made in rubles
um hello and thank you for inviting me
today um i think first of all this is a
political statement and it's um
understandable in the current
geopolitical context uh context uh the
purpose of this announcement was
basically
uh to uh sort of
it it should be viewed as a
sanction um in response to the west
imposing biting sanctions on russia and
it has been targeted at so-called
unfriendly countries which have imposed
such sanctions
but actually if we look at the mechanism
itself which russia has proposed
it doesn't actually demand uh
european buyers to pay in rubles
it
demands them to pay
into
accounts and gasps from bank
which uh and payments can be made in the
regional currency of the contract uh
whether well mostly euros um and the the
trick here is that the uh this money is
going to be then converted into rubles
in russia so strictly speaking
the decree which putin signed does not
demand payment and rubles okay the ruble
itself is on slightly firmer ground
right now it's it's risen against the
dollar and and the euro a a touch
has russia avoided
uh the worst of uh
what the sanctions were designed to do
i mean is it going to avoid an economic
collapse
uh well yes we we can actually say that
the first uh phase of this crisis
uh is uh has now finished and actually
the russian authorities have managed to
avoid
um
you know
the meltdown in the banking sector for
example or a complete meltdown in the fx
market and this was done by a
combination of capital controls and a
huge
rate hike which the central bank
implemented in the days after the
invasion so the rate hike was
1050 basis points which is very large
and uh the capital controls are
preventing uh investors from
uh moving their funds out of russia
which is reducing the pressure on the
ruble so if you look at where the ruble
is trading now is actually
uh trading at stronger levels versus u.s
dollar than it was in the in the days
preceding the beginning of this uh
conflict all right so the economy is is
weathering the storm for the moment but
for for how long can it continue to do
so
well there are some long-term processes
which now have been launched in the
economy
uh a deep restructuring of the equipment
deep changes will be happening to the
structure of the economy uh as russia is
going to pivot away from europe uh
towards asia
so uh trade ties are going to be cut
they're already being cut with the
western buyers of russian exports
self-sanctioning and curtailing
their imports of
russian commodities mostly
russia is no longer
able to import a lot of
goods from the countries which have
imposed sanctions against it so these
processes have already been launched
it's just the matter of months and
perhaps years before before we can see
the full impact of these measures and
the country is i mean there's no doubt
the country is headed for for quite a
deep recession isn't it
yes it is our current forecast uh view
sees a recession of about well
contraction and the uh
output of about 10 this year and further
three percent next year and what impact
is all of that going to have on the cost
of living for ordinary
russians the cost of living has already
increased considerably uh prices
increased uh in march by 7.6 percent
versus their level in february february
so it was quite a sharp shock but after
that actually the price grows slowed
down because as i have said the uh ruble
exchange rate stabilized and returned to
its previous level so
there is no further pressure on prices
from the currency side and we mentioned
a few moments ago that um the country
has managed to to to pay off some of it
of its debt what are the long-term
prospects on that can russia afford to
keep servicing it its debt is there a
danger somewhere down the line if this
economic pressure continues for for
maybe one two
years or longer of russia defaulting on
its debt
well um russia has a very low level of
government debt
so i think that even despite the current
measures uh measures currently discussed
by the european union
regarding the
phasing out russian
oil and gas i think still russia still
should be able to pay its uh
its debt
um if the oil price at some point in the
future collapses as it has happened in
the past then uh the situation will
probably change but at the moment the
main risk of russian default is stemming
from its ability to actually perform
these payments it's effectively up to
u.s authorities whether to allow
u.s banks to process further debt
payments by the russian government so
this is where the main risk is
great to talk to you on counting the
cost many thanks indeed for being with
us
thank you for inviting me again now it's
known for global hits like squid game
money heists and the crown
netflix has been top of the league in
streaming services for a long time now
but pandemic restrictions that kept
people glued to their screens are
receding competition is getting tougher
and netflix is losing subscribers for
the first time in a decade the platform
lost 200 000 subscribers in the first
three months of the year and expects to
lose 2 million more in the second
quarter the announcement sent the
company's stock down more than 35
percent last week wiping at least 54
billion dollars off its market value
netflix generated revenue of almost 8
billion in the first three months of the
year but that marked a slow down from
previous quarters while profits fell by
more than six percent
and it's not only netflix that has faced
a slump shares in disney roku paramount
and warner brothers discovery have also
slipped while cnn is shutting down its
streaming service cnn plus just a month
after it was launched on the flip side
hbo at hbo max had almost 78 million
subscribers at the end of the first
quarter of 2022 that's around a 13
million year-on-year increase
joining us from london tim mulligan he's
a senior analyst and research director
at media research tim good to have you
with us where's it all gone wrong for
netflix
that's a a big question um
simply poor netflix have
reached a certain level of growth and
development where the easy wins for
continuing that rapid growth trajectory
over the previous decade are no longer
there
and principally that comes from two key
areas one is competition in their core
markets predominantly the domestic
market the us which still accounts for
over a third of their subscribers but
then it's where the growth has been
coming over the last few years ever
since they made the pivot back in 2017
to focus on international subscribers
that growth is leveling off because
they're moving into markets that don't
actually have the discretionary income
to be able to afford monthly
subscriptions so
the competition are now moving into our
supported propositions and this is
something that netflix has noticeably uh
pushed back against having as part of
their offering their core usp is an ad
free on-demand viewing experience the
the final observation make about why
netflix is starting to struggle with
growth and retention
is a combination of their portfolio of
content
so they noticeably don't have news and
nursery don't have sports in their
lineup now this is essential to be able
to offer a
streaming tv alternative to traditional
pay tv which is effectively what we're
talking about here subscription video
services are streaming is streaming pay
tv so they lack that some of the other
notable competitors moving um into the
market over the last three years have
that and that's something they lack so
something that they may want to
reconsider the other final piece is to
ask for why netflix is currently in this
uh
this this challenging position
is we're entertaining what media calls
the attention recession now attention
recession is when
the combination of the long-term
strategic limits
of uh of being able to engage because of
organic constraints of sleep
are also matched by the return of in
real life entertainment alternatives and
people are able to get out of their
homes and able to socialize again they
will do all the traditional
entertainment formats that weren't
available during the lockdown
remember that there are still parts of
the world that are coming out of that
lockdown period so inevitably that
combines with this long-term secular uh
peak in attention engagement to create
an attention recession have we passed
peak streaming do you think do you think
the market is just too saturated
yes
and no it's a qualified yes no because
what
what we're experiencing here is a
transition from traditional tv
consumption to streaming tv consumption
we're moving into the streaming tv era
so that still means that there are some
uh legacy behaviors around traditional
linear tv consumption that will migrate
over to streaming but what is
undoubtable is we've also got these
constraints and the amount of time that
can be spent with home entertainment the
return of in real life entertainment
the looming attention recession means
that growth is not no longer going to be
easily found and the other aspect of
this is the subscription model of
streaming services today the
predominantly subscription subscription
model is now being augmented and will
inevitably be surpassed by app supported
streaming in the same way traditional tv
has been divided between pay tv
and through broadcast tv broadcast tv
has traditionally been the majority of
the market the majority consumers
are willing to tolerate adverts
to engage with content it's the minority
who are willing to pay for an ad free
experience so that will inevitably
translate into streaming especially as
this becomes a global phenomenon and
moves beyond developed markets which are
now increasingly saturated with
subscription services fascinating tim
it's been really good to talk to you
many thanks indeed for being with us on
counting the cost
you're welcome thank you for your time
and that's our show for this week don't
forget if you want to get in touch with
us about anything you've seen you can
tweet me i'm at a finnegan
on twitter please use the hashtag ajctc
when you do or you can drop us a line
counting the cost aljazeera.net is our
email address as always there's plenty
more for you online at altazero.com ctc
that takes you straight to our page and
there you'll find individual reports
links even entire episodes for you to
catch up on
but that is it for this edition of
counting the cost i'm adrian finnegan
from the whole team here in doha thanks
for being with us the news is next on al
jazeera
you